switching gears now we're sharing a
story about an extraordinary discovery
we told you at the top of the broadcast
about a husband and wife team in england
who search for fossils for why fun
scientists say that they dug up an
unprecedented collection of tiny fossils
from the time when dinosaurs roam the
earth they say the ancient skeletons can
teach us about our planet's past and
even the future roxanna sibiri has the
story
deep in the english countryside or more
precisely under it
scientists are digging for treasure at a
site that's for now a secret it's
possible that people could trespass on
this land
and poach away this material
jeff thompson an american researcher at
london's natural history museum is
helping to unearth this material around
167 million years old several thousand
ancestors of today's starfish feather
stars sea cucumbers and sea lilies many
with their fragile skeletons still
intact and what we've got here are some
really spectacularly preserved fossil
sea urchins in fact i can say these are
some of the best i've ever seen in the
field in my life how rare is it to find
fossils that are this well preserved
pretty rare
very very rare their final moments
captured in what may have been a
mudslide back when the site was covered
by a shallow sea they were probably
buried with sediment while they were
alive that results in the best
preservation
but these paleontologists wouldn't have
known where to look
if it weren't for two amateur sleuths
neville hollingworth and his wife sally
for them fossil hunting has been a long
time hobby how did you guys find this
place well it all started during the
lockdown
using satellite images like these from
google earth they pinpointed this
limestone quarry where did you start
yeah
just about here yes
they took a slab home and carefully
cleaned it revealing a smorgasbord of
history this is a jurassic buffet really
you've got everything here that was
living on the seabed at the time they
really sort of struck gold what kind of
gold well fossil gold so yeah not not
actual gold
but probably something better in my
opinion it's absolutely fantastic in
fact says museum curator tim ewan this
could be one of the world's biggest
discoveries of fossils like these from
the jurassic era what is the
significance globally it's really to
understand
how those
animals came to be
and how they survived previous periods
of mass extinction and climate change
life has survived and come back but it's
the amount of time it's taken to come
back and looking and understanding that
sequence of events in the fossil record
gives us a very stark warning
back at the museum each slab is dusted
off grained by grain and identified this
one right here is an exceptional
specimen so i would be able to go
look at this with a microscope probably
figure out what species it belongs to
so far the scientists have discovered
three new species of common sea
creatures we have here a brittle star
here we have a sea cucumber and over
here we've got the underside of a
starfish
before this the museum had collected
only about 25 specimens over the past
two centuries
now the team is pouring over more than a
thousand new ones
there are probably years of
being involved in this material to come
we're all fossil detectives here when
we're actually piecing together the
little bits of a jigsaw it's bright pink
oh my god a jigsaw that could give us a
glimpse of our future
for cbs mornings
roxanna saberi from somewhere in the
english countryside
all right roxanna thank you the
enthusiasm yeah yeah
they're lovely they're a sweet couple i
can imagine you know it would be
thrilling to hold something in your hand
that is two million years old or
whatever the the number is it's just
buffet i was gonna nate i wrote that
down too because two words i never
thought i'd see together in the same
sentence yeah yeah very strong t-shirt
game in that package as well that's a
fact like a cake on that one shirt not
sure